One of the main motivations for the rise
of virtual networking was the" ossification" of the
internet architecture. In particular because the internet protocol
was so pervasive, it made it very difficult
to make fundamental changes to the way the
underlying internet architecture operated. There was a lot
of work on overlay networks in the 2000's
but one size fits all network architectures were very
difficult to deploy. So rather than try
to replace existing network architectures, network virtualization
was intended to allow for easier evolution.
In other words, network virtualization enables evolution because
we didn't have to pick a winner for a replacement for IP. We could
instead let multiple architectures exist in parallel.
Now, this was sort of a green field
view of why virtual networking was potentially a good idea. In practice, network
virtualization has really taken off in multi
-tenant data centers where there may be
multiple tenants or applications running on
a shared cluster of servers. Well know
examples of this include Amazon's EC2, Rack
Space, and things like Google App Engine.
Large service providers such as Google, Yahoo
and so forth also use network virtualization
to adjust the resources that are devoted
to any particular service at a given time.